I have used microaggressions against my
own race I man I hated being Asian
growing up I despised it and I just
remember making the crudest most
horrible jokes because in in some way I
felt like this was expected of me to
make everyone feel comfortable about my
adoption
what is the experience like for
transracial adoptees in America we
partnered with Lionsgate on their
upcoming film Joyride to hear the
stories of real life adoptees and how
their experiences shaped their lives
adopted kids are more screwed up than
biological kids
three two one go
I'm really curious about YouTubers yeah
I know so many biological kids that are
screwed up
they were raised in like a healthy
nuclear cliche white picket fence family
and I know several adopted kids that are
so successful that are doing great I
mean
shout out Simone biles she went to the
Olympics and she was adopted can I move
like she changed my mind a bit like come
on
like she has a point there I can't no I
can I strongly disagree with that no
because like the thing is she changed my
mind on that because like as a foster
kid I like somebody who went through all
that we are up you know like we
we go through so much like do that whole
process seeing and feeling neglected
from like the foster parents but I don't
let my past where I grew up like Define
who I am to make me screw screwed up
yeah so um I don't strongly agree
because I've been through a few
therapeutic boring schools Wilderness
programs one of them I remember it's a
place where wealthy parents send their
children so it's privilege and even with
all that privilege everybody there was
messed up like and messed up just saying
like they weren't stable whether it was
a drug addiction or just like bad temper
or violence adoptees all carry this
trauma maybe it has something to do with
identity and not knowing a lot about our
background well some of us not knowing a
lot about our background I think like we
don't even have a birthday and me
personally going through that and
growing up in a colorblind environment
um it's kind of like we were left to
fend for ourselves and I think any
children have to fend for themselves are
going to go through so so
[Music]
thank you for sharing by the way I look
at this question through two lenses the
adopted Community as a whole is four
times more at risk of suicide than
non-adopted counterparts I think that
adopted kids are more at risk for
struggle
not because of us but because of society
and because of the dominant Narrative of
white saviorism that is all surrounding
adoption we all know this narrative but
the narrative for those that don't know
is this notion of adoptees should feel
lucky adoptees must be grateful and
gratitude is related to this idea of
repayment the effect of that is that we
as adoptees as a whole community
feel like we're less worth than our
non-adopted counterparts it makes us
feel like you should repay your life
that you were given you should repay the
fortunes that were given to you and for
little kids
how can we repay something that's
immeasurable
and it's not fair for us as little kids
to have that weight that burden on us
while growing up and because we have
that weight because we have that burden
that's what so to speak messes us up
you're bringing back some stuff I'm like
yeah
like Jesus I chose to be on this side
because I felt if I was on that side
it'd be denying my experiences in
adoptee uh the fear of Abandonment that
feels inherent to being an adoptee
because of that I have definitely been
in relationships I shouldn't have been
in toxic ones and relationships for way
too long what comes with that then is
like feeling like you have to prove that
you're worthy of Love constantly because
of the inner voids and wounds of being
abandoned as a baby or just abandoned in
general yeah yeah
hi my name is Mattea I am adopted from
China in the 90s during the one child
policy so um one thing I'm super
grateful about with my parents is they
really valued making sure that my
brother and I experienced Our Heritage
every summer we would go to this camp
that specifically focused on our Chinese
Heritage and taught us different aspects
of it so like language calligraphy dance
martial arts and so that was a really
special and I think important experience
to have as a transracial adoptee hi my
name is Eli I'm 23 years old and I was
adopted from South Korea at nine months
old I have four adopted siblings also
from Korea and I grew up in Denver
Colorado so not a lot of diversity there
and I'm actually about to go look for my
birth parents this fall
hello good humans we hope you're
enjoying this very special episode of
spectrum I'm here with the director of
this episode Liz
hey everyone we're excited to be
partnering with Lion's gate in bringing
together this group of trans-racial
adoptees to promote their upcoming movie
this movie centers around a group of
friends who embark on a crazy journey
across Asia with Audrey and Asian women
who's adopted by white parents to find
her birth mother and it ends up being a
trip full of twists and turns that's
heartfelt and hilarious as a trans
racial adopting myself I love that an
adopting narrative can Crush genres into
a wild comedy but my favorite part of it
is that there's such a Powerhouse cast
of aapi actors some of our very favorite
people like Ashley Parr Sherry Cola
Stephanie Shu Sabrina Wu uh and many
more surprises there's definitely some
pretty raunchy moments in the movie but
I love that it really just breaks the
mold of how the API Community has been
portrayed on screen up until now yeah it
is fresh and I felt uncomfortable
watching it with my mother so please go
watch with your mother Joyride is coming
out in theaters on July 7th and you can
buy your tickets now our right now let's
get back to the episode we'll see you
guys bye
transracial adoption should not be
allowed
three two one go
I mean I think it makes sense yeah well
transracial adoptees that would be
saying that you would be against your
own adoption and I think I just want to
add also it's different from being
colorblind that's not why I'm here just
clarifying okay theoretically let's say
we were on agree for one reason do you
guys have any gripes against transracial
adoption
um well yeah like I I guess like what I
just said a little bit Xavier complex
save your complex I mean there are
people in the world who I think view
transracial adoption as this like
oh I'm doing a cool thing like I've met
people who have said those specific
things where they're like I've always
just wanted a black child you know but
there's that's it there's no like why do
you want a black child or you know or
like it was like a savior mentality
almost and I do think that it's really
important as the further we go to have
that education and to not go in with it
with the colorblind stance because it
does do a lot more harm at least it did
for me growing up
um then yeah just opening up your kids
to the culture that they came from yeah
no you really spoke to something all my
friends that are black or Arabic
um have all this culture that they grew
up with and they like years and years of
like learning stuff and that's what I
missed out on so for the future
generations and people who are adopting
right now I think the biggest thing
would be to stop being colorblind
because we're not helping the kids yeah
I agree that everybody deserves a set of
parents family everybody deserves to be
loved and nurtured and care for however
the recent legislation that almost
didn't pass I guess for iqua which is
the indigenous child welfare act being
Native American and not adopted by
Native Americans I don't know anything
you know there's so much about my life
that just didn't make sense until I went
out and learned it myself so I feel like
that small community of native children
need to stay with other natives it
doesn't have to be the same tribe but
just
keep them native because you know our
population is declining
I mean I am standing here where I am but
I do think it is a little bit of a
privileged place to be standing because
I think the reality of adoption in the
U.S and culture in the U.S is that it's
very hard to be a person of color here
in this country you know my parents were
white
my parents being white will never
understand what it's like to be a person
of color in the U.S yeah and they're not
going to be able to connect with me in
that way which is kind of a big deal now
there are other things that they do
really really well but the reality is
living here is kind of tough for a
person of color and they can recognize
that for me but they can't know what my
experience is yeah
hey everyone my name is Ben I was a
doctor from China at 11 months by my
dad's Bill and Sam and I grew up in New
York City hi my name is Nora so a little
bit about my adoption story I was found
in a hole in a park by a police officer
when I was about I think it was a week
or two old so a little bit about my
adopted parents
um they're both white French Canadians
my parents were infertile they couldn't
have their own children but my mother
always had a strong need to be a mother
and to have a family so I think yeah
it's always been important so it was
children or it had to be okay let's mix
it up can each of you tell me some of
the crazy stuff that people have said to
you as a transracial adoptee okay
um who are your parents because my
parents are white so they never know
where they are in the crowd do you know
your real parents though what country
are you originally from oh yeah where
are you from from I just get made fun of
being adopted so I would say my parents
chose me yours just stuck with what they
got
[Music]
they're so lucky
congrats oh that was a big one people
would literally be like congratulations
for what are your parents coming to the
parent meeting conference they never
came
or are they coming to your football game
never came
for me it actually comes from other
Asians so the microaggressions like yeah
Eli's white or hey if we go to a potluck
you can bring a meatloaf right reset
yeah
it's very common yeah how's it going my
name is Prodigy I'm actually 21 years
old I went through the adoption process
a lot later than other people like I
went through the foster care system
basically how it all started for me it
was having a little bit of problems at
the start with my own family
and it led to me being taken away from
you know from our mother so I'm only got
a Wednesday and I'm Honduran and My
adoptive parents they're actually
Salvadorian and you know even though we
are from the same branch in Central
America at the end of the day is that
everybody has the different cultures
like when Nicaragua Honduras like they
were at War at some point in Salvador at
first it was a little bit of trouble but
at the end of the day like they're still
my family I can still go to their house
and eat in the same table with them but
like I said I'm a product Hispanic
I have used microaggressions against my
own race
three two one go
um
I think when I was younger it was
definitely some jokes that I made which
I deeply regret but trust me I'm picking
up the slack now but I think it also the
fact that I was growing up Countryside
in like a predominantly white Place made
it so that like I accepted a lot of
things little comments or little jokes
that would just let slide or people
using the n-word and I think when I
started learning more about Black
Culture
um that's when I was like okay that's
really not okay and this is why but I
think that also comes with maturity in
age
so I'm on strongly agree because I man I
hated being Asian growing up I despised
it man my dad would give me a buzz cut I
had classes and so every time I went out
we just kind of would get looks because
there's five adopted kids and man I just
remember making the crudest most
horrible jokes
um because it in a weird way it
validated me as like an Asian almost
because in in some way I felt like this
is what was expected of me to make these
jokes to make these comments to make
everyone laugh and feel comfortable
about my adoption and what I realized is
dang like first off I'm starting to
believe this stuff second off
I'm doing it in service of others like
I'm making these jokes to make other
people feel comfortable I do identify
with your story as well
um I grew up also like hating that I was
Asian but like specifically Chinese
um I would hear like kind of a negative
connotation about Chinese that like
they're liars and they're ugly and also
being around predominantly a white
community and like in high school like
hanging out with a lot of group of girls
that were often white and I was the
token Asian like just made me more and
more hate my appearance and not think
that I was attractive I guess with being
insecure with that it's almost like yeah
that internalized racism and like
self-hatred that happens so that's why I
am on this side as well oh can I add one
thing to that yeah like totally totally
totally resonant with what both of you
guys were saying I was always proud to
be Asian I was proud of my differences
but I think it was always interesting
Reckoning with this idea of being
proximal to whiteness and what I mean by
that is when white people
growing up said oh like you're basically
white they were saying that to validate
me as being like a a first-class citizen
because I'm like almost white because I
was raised in a white family
and that when Asians would call me a
banana or when Asians would say oh well
you're not really Asian
um
that would hurt on a different level
yeah
because of course we are Asian and yeah
it just feels incredibly invalidating
I mean for me like I'm on strongly
disagree because I'm a proud Hispanic
like I'm nicaraguance and I'm Honduran
and I'm always gonna be proud of that no
matter what and I get how some people
can be like Oh My Race like it falls in
my bloodline that like there's
alcoholism drug addicts but I'm never
gonna let that Define my anger or my
percentage of how I am or how I
represent myself ever yes uh so I would
say with my family like cousins
grandparents all of that and the
conversation of my adoption didn't
really start happening until like when
Mike Brown was shot that was kind of the
first time that I really felt
invalidated by my own family because I
think I was trying to get them to
recognize like I'm a black woman and
there are people right now who look like
me that are going through very traumatic
things
um but my family didn't view it that way
I felt very invisible yeah I didn't have
anyone to relate to
um all my family comes from a really
small town in the midwest like 95 white
and to the point where like the KKK it
used to be a sun downtown like that kind
of thing and so yeah I growing up it
just went from
I was just kind of there as Michaela but
not a black person it was more of just
like they would always say to me is like
I don't see you as black yeah you know
and another time and I was happy I was
glad I was like yes I'm not gonna like
be a victim of racism yeah yes at the
time exactly yeah it never bothered me
at the time but I think the more I
processed it the older I got I realized
how damaging that term is because I mean
I think we've all experienced this of
like
who am I and so then I was like okay if
these my family doesn't see me as black
what am I you know that was like the
question that I still sometimes think
today even that's like always in the
back of my head so yeah
hundred percent so true hi I'm Michaela
I was adopted two days after I was born
in the suburbs of Indianapolis by a
single white mother I met my birth
family when I was 18 years old I found
them on Facebook and it was definitely a
whirlwind of emotions I went from
basically just being me to finding out I
have five siblings and like hundreds of
family members that all tried to contact
me within the span of 24 hours so it was
a pretty overwhelming experience and I'm
27 now but yeah I'm hoping again to have
just to build a relationship with them
in the future hi I'm Chris I was adopted
when I was four years old by polish
immigrants they had just immigrated to
America in the early 90s and decided
that they wanted children and due to
medical reasons they were unable to
conceive so they adopted a little Native
American baby
which is me
nature is stronger than nurture
three two one go
nature is stronger than nurture so your
genetics are stronger than how you were
raised oh yeah okay
is that it correctly we just yeah yeah
it's just all the trauma you know
um
I want to know like why do you agree
like out of everybody here you know so I
was raised by Conservative Christian
parents
and I do not look like a Conservative
Christian whatsoever growing up in a
very strict no alcohol
no drugs no gambling no tattoos being
gay is not okay marriage is for a man
and a woman here I am
you know in a same-sex relationship
covered in tattoos both of my biological
parents suffered tremendously with their
mental health they were in and out of
you know mental facilities I mean not to
be cliche but two out of every three
Native American struggles with addiction
and I did struggle with homelessness and
addiction just like my parents did I
read the Bible cover to cover growing up
and I still made the choices and had the
journey that I had
I'm neutral for the fact that like at
some point it was nature genetically my
dad drank a little bit my mom she
suffered through Mental Health
and you know I remember being a kid
seeing all of that but I don't let that
Define me because genetically like I
said you can stop genetically the nature
of where you're surrounding that's
exactly what what I'm trying to do I'm
the first person in my biological family
to go to college you know I you know
thank you just got accepted to a UC
thank you thank you it's never too late
to get an education but you know like
I'm I'm on that path trying to make a
better life for myself yeah being a
criminologist
um nature versus nurture is one of the
biggest dilemmas and after almost 10
years studying I'm here because I see
that environment affects people
tremendously whether you're still with
your biological parents whether you're
adopted foster care doesn't matter for
example crime or criminality can be
developed by your environment if you
grew up in like white Suburbia white
picket fans a lot of money or if you
grew up or in a family where everybody
is Gang Related who has the who is going
has more chance of developing
criminality right and
it's not necessarily
who your parents are or your bloodline
so that's why I'm on you surround
yourself with yeah
um so I met my family
um when yeah when I was 18. I went to a
family reunion that was kind of like my
first big thing where I like met
everyone
um like over 100 people I went by myself
I definitely felt out of place I was
like these are the people who are my
blood and I look like them but I also
felt like a stranger still
um and I think that just goes into the
identity piece that made it even harder
for me because I was like finally met my
birth family but these people do not
feel like family at all
um but also my birth dad there's things
that I see in him especially like when
I'm angry we act the same or like
there's things from my birth moms that
we just both like like she grew up doing
that I've noticed that I do as well so I
definitely think there are things that
like I've seen from my family that I've
noticed in me but I also still feel
Like a Stranger at the same time I feel
like also like children babies like we
mimic a lot yeah so like even I know
this is about trans racial adoptions but
if you look at just same race adoption
people would be like you're back there
but you look so much like your parents
are you yeah they get that all the time
well it's because you have the same
mannerisms I have the same mannerism
with my mom like but people won't really
seek those out or look for that or
notice it because I'm my parents my mom
is white and I'm black I am very much
like my dad and very logical very
emotional like my mother I've not gotten
the chance to meet my birth family yet I
also grew up very very Christian very
very conservatively and I think that did
impact me quite a bit so I I think that
it's a push and pull for certain things
that our nature and versus certain
things that are nurtured so I don't
think there's an answer for it but in
terms of transracial adoption
I do want to think about the point of
why the question was asked in the first
place which I don't quite understand
where the question is coming from
blood yeah blood blood versus not blood
blood versus water there you go oh well
uh well my tangent is a really long
tangent so I can go for it I'm lost okay
[Music]
so I totally agree that we have like
different brain chemistries like I'm
predisposed to maybe being a little bit
more confident or maybe more happier
whatever it may be there's
neurodiversity that being said I don't
like this question and maybe this is why
what you're getting at I don't like this
question because I think it takes away
the responsibility of community
of environment of society
and of government
and what I mean by that is
when we were born in some place and we
had no choice to be born and then we
when we were displaced and brought up in
a completely new environment
there is responsibility for the people
closest to us and for the community in
the neighborhood to be supporting and
championing that person and seeing them
not as the ones that are lucky or are
grateful but seeing them as the people
that are strong and are resilient and
people that we should Champion into
society
um and that's the responsibility of the
people that made a choice that we didn't
make as adoptees yeah so I you know I
contest this question by saying
who cares about nature versus nurture
nurture is pretty darn important
it's more important than nature I feel
like you have to understand the nature
in order to correctly nurture
because if you don't nurture based on
nature
you might not like educate them
correctly
yes yeah really well said I'm very happy
to be celebrating everyone's differences
today hearing each of your stories and
the impact that I know you guys are
making in your personal lives like it's
very cool and just know that I'm
celebrating you today yes I'm just happy
I can finally have trauma buddies to
talk to this about you know what I mean
yeah
[Applause]
adoption on three okay
trouble three one two three